Ho, Ho, Ho – Jack Pop hier.
Das ist unser erstes gemeinsames Weihnachten.
Deswegen frohes Fest Euch allen.
Und wenn ihr gestern Geschenke unterm Baum
gefunden habt, dann lasst euch noch eins gesagt
sein, Ihr habt keine Ahnung, wie schwer es
war, die dort hinzubekommen.
Denn der Weihnachtsmann, das Christkind oder
wem auch immer Ihr Euren Wunschzettel geschickt
habt, muss sich am Rande des physikalisch
möglichen bewegen, um das alles fristgerecht
auszuliefern.
Aber die Wissenschaft kann ein paar nützliche
Tipps liefern, die wir uns heute gemeinsam
anschauen werden.
Sehr, sehr artige Kinder klicken am Anfang
aber bitte noch auf abonnieren.
Und dann kannst du losgehen.
So eine Paket-Tour rund um den Globus, ist
echt kein Zuckerstangen schlecken.
Immerhin gibt es weltweit rund 2 Milliarden
Kinder.
Okay, die feiern nicht alle Weihnachten und
nicht überall fällt Weihnachten auf denselben
Tag, aber selbst wenn man das nur regional
betrachtet, sieht man eigentlich, wie krass
das ist.
Deswegen lasst uns mal für diese Folge nur
von Deutschland ausgehen.
Bei uns gibt es 14 Millionen Haushalte in
denen Kinder leben.
Das macht mindestens 14 Millionen Geschenke.
Und da geht es schon los.
Punkt 1: Der Weihnachtsmann müsste extrem
viel Gewicht transportieren.
Wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, dass ein Geschenk
ungefähr ein Kilo wiegt, dann sind wir schon
bei 14.000 Tonnen angekommen.
Plus 150 Kilogramm für den übergewichtigen
Weihnachtsmann.
Wenn wir das jetzt alles in die Luft bekommen
wollen, dann bräuchten wir Eines der größten
Frachtflugzeuge der Welt, also entweder die
Antonow An-225 oder den brandneuen Stratolaunch
Roc.
Allerdings 56 Mal, denn jedes dieser Flugzeuge
schafft nur 250 Tonnen Nutzlast pro Flug.
Nun hat der Weihnachtsmann aber bekanntlich
keine Antonow, sondern lässt Rentiere schuften.
Sie können aber nur 250 Kilogramm Gewicht
ziehen.
Das heißt, mit zwölf Tieren plus Rudolph
an der Spitze wäre dieser Lastentransport
gnadenlos unterdimensioniert.
Allein für die Geschenke in Deutschland bräuchte
man 93.000 Rentiere, damit sich der Schlitten
überhaupt vom Platz bewegt.
Wenn Ihr denkt 93.000, Rentiere sind schon
viel, dann wisst ihr leider gar nichts über
Rentierherden.
Die können nämlich noch viel größer werden.
Die allergrößte gab es im Jahr 2000 in Russland.
Die hatte 1 Millionen Tiere okay.
Nehmen wir an, wir hätten diese 93.000 Rentiere.
Dann bliebe das größte Problem ja weiterhin
offen, denn die sollen ja fliegen können.
Was sie aber bekanntlich nicht tun.
Können wir da nicht einfach Vögel nehmen?
Nein, die können höchstens eine Pizza transportieren,
das haben wir hier bereits für euch durchgespielt.
Und an sich sind Rentiere auch die perfekten
Nutztiere für kalte nächtliche Touren.
Können blöderweise nicht fliegen und sind
außerdem noch zu langsam.
Die bringen nämlich höchstens 80 Kilometer
pro Stunde auf den Tacho.
Und da ist ein Problem.
Denn 2.: Der Weihnachtsmann müsste extrem
schnell unterwegs sein.
Wenn wir es nur für Deutschland betrachten,
wo die Bescherung klassischerweise zwischen
16 und 20 Uhr stattfindet, dann haben der
Weihnachtsmann oder Christkind nur vier Stunden
Zeit, um 14 Millionen Haushalte zu besuchen.
Für jeden dieser 14 Millionen Stops wäre
dann für die reine Lieferung nur eine Millisekunde
lang Zeit.
Also das heißt anhaltend Kaminrunde, Geschenke
platzieren, Kekse essen, Kamin wieder rauf,
ersten Gang einlegen und weiterfliegen.
Und das ohne Berücksichtigung der Flugzeit.
Die muss ja auch noch in diese vier Stunden
reinpassen.
Um rauszukriegen, wie schnell der Weihnachtsmann
sein müsste, um die reine Strecke zurückzulegen,
müssen wir ein bisschen Mathe machen.
In Deutschland leben die Menschen auf einer
Fläche von 3,8 Milliarden Quadratmeter, das
ist die Wohnfläche.
Laut Umweltbundesamt nehmen wir an die 14.
Millionen Haushalte würden sich gleichmäßig
auf diese Fläche verteilen.
Dann beansprucht jede Wohnung und jedes Haus
eine Grundfläche von rund 271 Quadratmetern,
also ein Quadrat mit einer Seitenlänge von
16,5 Metern.
Wenn wir jetzt die Wohnung und die Häuser
mittig platzieren, dann ergibt sich von Schornstein
zu Schornstein idealerweise ein Abstand von
auch 16,5 Metern.
16,5 Meter mal 14 Millionen Haushalte ergibt
eine Gesamtstrecke von 231.000 Kilometer,
die der Weihnachtsmann zu bewerkstelligen
hätte.
Wenn wir das jetzt auf die vier Stunden runter
brechen, die er Zeit hat, dann ergibt sich
daraus eine Geschwindigkeit von 57.750 Kilometern
pro Stunde.
Das ist ungefähr so schnell wie die New Horizons
Sonde der NASA, die schnellste unbemannte
Sonde, die die Menschheit je gebaut hat.
Die Frage ist also wie um alles in der Welt
kann der Weihnachtsmann so schnell werden?
Ganz einfach.
Der lässt die Rentiere weg und nimmt stattdessen
Antimaterie.
Antimaterie hat die entgegengesetzte Ladung
von normaler Materie, also zu einem negativ
geladenen Elektron gibt es ein positiv geladenes
Positron und zu einem positiv geladenen Proton,
gibt es auch ein negativ geladenes Antiproton
und so weiter.
Wenn man jetzt mal Materie und Antimaterie
zusammenbringt dann passiert etwas Verrücktes,
die löschen sich beide gegenseitig aus, und
dabei wird Energie freigesetzt.
Extrem viel Energie.
Ein Löffel Materie auf einen Löffel Antimaterie
würde eine Explosion hervorrufen, die eine
Großstadt zerstören könnte mit der Sprengkraft
von 200.000 Tonnen TNT.
Wegen dieser großen Energiefreisetzung ist
Antimaterie sogar als künftige Antriebsart
von Raumschiffen im Gespräch und am CERN,
an der Grenze zwischen Frankreich und der
Schweiz, da gibt es tatsächlich ein Antimaterie-Labor.
Also das Zeug wird da wirklich hergestellt.
Das Problem ist, Antimaterie ist sehr teuer,
weil extrem viel Energie benötigt wird, um
sie herzustellen.
Ein Kilo würde das CERN rund zweieinhalb
Billionen Euro kosten.
Und Kilos kann man davon eh noch nicht herstellen,
bislang nur wenige einzelne Antiprotonen.
Aber prinzipiell geht das schon heute.
Und hey, wer sich einen Schlitten aus Carbon-Gehäuse
für lächerliche 241.000 Euro leisten kann,
so wie man ihn auf dieser Website kaufen kann,
der hat doch wohl noch ein bisschen Geld für
Antimaterie übrig.
Einen Haken hat die Sache aber, beziehungsweise
3.
Also 1. wenn der Weihnachtsmann in kurzer
Zeit auf so krasse Geschwindigkeiten kommt,
dann wären die resultierenden Beschleunigungskräfte
so stark, dass es ihm regelrecht zermatschen
würde.
2. überschreitet er die Fluchtgeschwindigkeit
der Erde.
Das ist die Geschwindigkeit, die Raketen brauchen,
um sich von der Schwerkraft lösen zu können.
Das heißt ohne permanente Kurskorrektur wäre
der Weihnachtsmann auf direktem Wege ins All.
Und 3. gibt es bei diesen Geschwindigkeiten
einen enormen Luftwiderstand.
Das kennt man von Raumschiffen, die wieder
in die Atmosphäre eintreten, da bildet sich
auch so ein Hitze-Kegel.
Genau das passiert: extrem viel Reibung erzeugt
extrem viel Hitze und Santa und seine Rentiere
würden halt einfach in der Atmosphäre verglühen.
Die beste Idee wäre aber so eine Art Wurmloch-Generator,
mit dem der Weihnachtsmann sich durch Abkürzungen
in der Raumzeit viel schneller von Ort zu
Ort bewegen könnte.
Physikalisch betrachtet, ist das nicht unmöglich.
Es gibt aber noch andere Tricks, mit denen
er zumindest seinen Aufwand reduzieren könnte.
Zum Beispiel mit Punkt 3: Er müsste die perfekte
Route haben.
Der Weihnachtsmann, St.
Nikolaus, das Christkind oder wie er genannt
wird, sie alle haben ein klassisches Problem
der Mathematik zu lösen, nämlich das Problem
des Handelsreisenden.
Dabei geht es darum, eine Menge von Punkten
so miteinander zu verbinden, dass sich eine
optimale Route ergibt.
Das ist das Haus vom Nikolaus.
Nehmen wir an, Deutschland hätte nur 4 Städte,
dann gebe es schon sechs mögliche Weihnachtsmann-Routen
beziehungsweise die Hälfte, denn die ersten
3 sind da nur die umgekehrte Variante von
den letzten 3.
Mit wachsender Anzahl von Städten wird das
Ganze aber immer komplizierter.
Bei 7 Städten gibt es schon 360 Möglichkeiten,
bei 10 sind 181.000, und bei 15 gibt es mehr
als 43 Millionen Möglichkeiten, diese miteinander
zu verbinden.
Und Deutschland hat gut 2.000 Städte.
Unmöglich ist es aber nicht.
Schaut mal: Das hier ist die perfekte Weihnachtsmann
Lieferroute für die USA.
Die haben Informatiker aus Kanada mit der
Hilfe von Algorithmen berechnet.
Denn Algorithmen sind in der Lage, sich solchen
komplexen mathematischen Problemen anzunehmen
und zu akzeptablen Lösungen zu kommen.
Damit spart der Weihnachtsmann also eine Menge
Zeit und Nerven.
Und er könnte sogar noch mehr Zeit sparen.
Im Idealfall kann er nämlich eine ganze Reihe
von Kindern einfach von der Lieferliste streichen.
Denn 4.: Der Weihnachtsmann beschenkt eh nur
Kinder in privilegierten Regionen, sagt eine
Studie aus Großbritannien von 2016.
Da hat ein Forschungsteam landesweit bei allen
Krankenhäusern angerufen, die eine Kinderstation
besitzen und gefragt, ob die von einem Weihnachtsmann
besucht worden ist oder nicht.
Ergebnis von 186 Kinderstationen sind 90 Prozent
besucht wurden aber die, die in sozial benachteiligten
Regionen lagen, sind häufiger nicht besucht
worden als die bessergestellten Regionen.
Interessant daran ist, dass der Besuch unabhängig
davon war, wie gut oder böse die Kids waren.
Statistisch betrachtet.
Das Forschungsteam hat sich nämlich die regionalen
Quoten beim Schulschwänzen angesehen und
auch die Jugendstraftaten und konnte rechnerisch
keine Zusammenhänge zwischen Besuchen und
Nicht-Besuchen ziehen.
Auch die Entfernung zum Nordpol haben die
sich angeschaut.
Und auch die hatte keinerlei Auswirkungen
auf die Visite.
Korrelationen ergaben sich tatsächlich nur
durch eine Kombination von sozioökonomischen
Faktoren der jeweiligen Region, also sowas
wie Einkommen, Arbeitslosigkeit, Kriminalitätsniveau,
Wohnungsmarkt und so weiter.
Warum das allerdings so ist, das konnte das
Forschungsteam nicht sagen, die schreiben,
letztlich könnten noch weitere Variablen
eine Rolle spielen.
Etwa die Qualität des Whiskys, der für ihn
im Krankenhaus abgelassen wurde, oder die
Verfügbarkeit von Kaminen und kostenlosen
Parkplätzen für Rentiere.
Ob der Weihnachtsmann hier aktiv diskriminiert
oder ob weitreichendere strukturelle Faktoren
im Spiel sind, muss in weiteren Studien untersucht
werden.
Na, wie hat Euch diese Folge gefallen?
Schreibts mal Jack Pop in die Kommentare.
Aber das Wichtigste: Ho ho holt Euch ein Abo!
Bis nächsten Mittwoch!